il est 9h ce matin quand les
propriétaires de ce champ de canne à
sucre découvre le corps sans vie d'un
homme d'une trentaine d'années il est
couché sur le ventre et baigne dans une
mare de sang
très vite gendarmerie médecin légiste
arrivent sur place pour déterminer les
circonstances de la mort
selon nos premières informations la
victime aurait reçu une balle en pleine
tête puis son corps auraient été jetés
ici
après le meurtre il s'agirait là du 14e
homicide par arme à feu depuis le début
de l'année un contexte qui inquiète
sérieusement les forces de l'ordre
s'il fallait pour tentative d'homicide
elle avait abouti approximativement à
72,9 je crains qu'on finisse par
s'habituer à ces actualités
hier encore il ya eu des tirs sur fort
de france dans différents quartiers bon
heureusement pour l'instant non pas du
nombre de blessés ni de nom mais ça
commence vraiment à des faits et vous
voyez on va finir par arriver comme le
département de la cance pour vous êtes à
homicide depuis vingt ans nous nous
situons de 18
on essaie de ce matin les gendarmes ont
passé au crible le terrain des caméras
de surveillance situées non loin de
cette route sont en ce moment analyse et
mais pour l'heure l'identité de la
victime reste inconnu